Un sueño maravilloso, papá".
Lo cantaba con la pasión y el deseo ardiente de una niña de nueve años
que, de hecho, tenía un sueño.
Mi sueño era ser actriz.
Lo cierto es que nunca había visto a nadie parecido a mí
en la televisión o en las películas,
y es verdad que mi familia, amigos y maestros me advertían constantemente
de que la gente como yo no triunfaba en Hollywood.
Pero yo era estadounidense.
Me habían enseñado a creer que cualquiera podía lograr lo que fuera,
sin importar el color de la piel,
el hecho de que mis padres fuesen inmigrantes hondureños
o que no tuviera dinero.
No necesitaba que mi sueño fuera fácil.
Solo necesitaba que fuera posible.
Con 15 años
participé en mi primer casting profesional.
Era un anuncio de tele por cable
o de pagadores de fianzas, no lo recuerdo.
(Risas)
Lo que sí recuerdo es que el director del casting me pidió:
"¿Podrías repetirlo pero esta vez sonando más latina?"
"Um. OK.
¿Quiere que lo diga en español?", pregunté.
"No, no, en inglés, pero sonando más latina".
"Bueno, soy latina, ¿no es así como suena una latina?".
Tras un largo e incómodo silencio,
finalmente dijo:
"OK, cariño, no importa, gracias por venir, ¡adiós!"
Tardé todo el trayecto de vuelta a casa en darme cuenta que con "sonar más latina"
me estaba pidiendo que chapurrease el inglés.
Y no entendía por qué el hecho
de que yo era una latina auténtica, de carne y hueso,
parecía no importar.
De todos modos, no conseguí el trabajo.
No conseguí muchos de los trabajos para los que la gente quería verme:
la novia del pandillero,
la ratera descarada,
la chola preñada número dos.
(Risas)
Este era el tipo de papeles disponibles para alguien como yo.
Alguien a quien miraban y consideraban demasiada morena, demasiada gorda,
demasiada pobre, muy poco sofisticada.
Estos papeles eran estereotipos
y no podían estar más lejos de mi realidad
o de los papeles que soñaba interpretar.
Quería interpretar personajes complejos y multidimensionales,
gente que existía en el centro de sus propias vidas.
No figuras de cartón plantadas en el fondo de vidas ajenas.
Pero cuando me atrevía a decírselo a mi representante,
la persona a quien pagaba para que me ayudase a encontrar una oportunidad,
su respuesta era:
"Alguien debe decirle a esta chica que sus expectativas no son realistas".
Y no se equivocaba.
Lo despedí, pero no se equivocaba.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Porque cuando trataba de conseguir un papel que no fuese un estereotipo,
me decían:
"No buscamos diversidad para este papel".
O: "Nos encanta, pero es demasiada específica étnicamente hablando".
O: "Por desgracia, ya tenemos un latino en esta película".
Seguía recibiendo el mismo mensaje una y otra vez.
Que mi identidad era un obstáculo que debía superar.
Y entonces pensé:
"Ven aquí, obstáculo.
Soy estadounidense. Me llamo América.
Me he preparado para esto toda mi vida, seguiré el guión
y me esforzaré más.
Y lo hice, me esforcé al máximo
para superar todas las cosas de mí que la gente decía que estaban mal.
Me alejaba del sol para que mi piel no se bronceara demasiado,
alisé mis rizos para dominarlos.
Intenté constantemente perder peso
y compré ropa más cara y de moda.
Todo para que al verme,
la gente no viese a una latina demasiada gorda, morena y pobre.
Verían de lo que era capaz.
Y quizá me darían una oportunidad.
En un irónico giro del destino,
cuando finalmente conseguí un papel que haría mis sueños realidad,
fue uno que requería que fuese exactamente quien yo era.
Ana en "Las mujeres de verdad tienen curvas"
era una latina morena, pobre y gorda.
Nunca había visto a nadie como ella,
a nadie como yo en el centro de su propia historia personal.
Viajé por todo EE.UU.
y a muchos países con esta película
en la que la gente, sin importar la edad, etnia o tipo de cuerpo,
se identificaba con Ana.
Una joven mexicana regordeta de 17 años
que luchaba contra las normas culturales para cumplir su sueño improbable.
A pesar de lo que me habían dicho toda mi vida,
vi de primera mano que la gente quería ver historias sobre gente como yo.
Y que mi expectativa poco realista
de verme representada de verdad en la cultura
también era la expectativa de muchos otros.
"Las mujeres de verdad tienen curvas"
fue un éxito de crítica, cultural y de recaudación.
"Genial", pensé. "¡Lo logramos!"
Demostramos que nuestras historias tenían valor.
"Las cosas van a cambiar ahora".
Pero vi que pasaban muy pocas cosas.
No hubo un antes y un después.
Nadie en la industria corría a contar más historias
a un público hambriento y dispuesto a pagar para verlas.
Cuatro años después, cuando protagonicé "Ugly Betty",
vi como sucedía el mismo fenómeno.
"Uggly Betty" se estrenó en EE.UU. para 16 millones de espectadores
y fue nominada a 11 Emmy en su primer año.
(Aplausos)
A pesar del éxito de "Ugly Betty",
no hubo otro programa de televisión
protagonizado por una latina
en la tele estadounidense durante 8 años.
Han pasado 12 años
desde que fui la primera y única latina
en ganar un Emmy como protagonista.
No es para estar orgulloso.
Es para sentirse muy frustrado.
No porque los premios demuestren nuestra valía,
sino porque los que vemos triunfar en el mundo
nos enseñan cómo nos vemos,
cómo nos valoramos
cómo soñar con el futuro.
Cuando me asaltan las dudas,
recuerdo que hubo una niña que vivía en el Valle de Swat, en Pakistán.
De algún modo, llegaron a sus manos unos DVD
de un programa estadounidense
en el que vio reflejado su propio sueño de ser escritora.
En su autobiografía, Malala escribió:
"Me interesé por el periodismo
tras ver cómo mis propias palabras podían marcar una diferencia
y tras ver los DVD de "Uggly Betty"
sobre la vida en una revista estadounidense".
(Aplausos)
Durante mis 17 años de trayectoria
he sido testigo del poder de nuestras voces
cuando tienen presencia en nuestra cultura.
Lo he visto.
Lo he vivido, todos lo hemos visto.
En el mundo del entretenimiento, en la política,
en los negocios, en los cambios sociales.
Es innegable: la presencia crea posibilidades.
Pero durante los últimos 17 años,
también he oído las mismas excusas
sobre por qué algunos de nosotros podemos estar presentes en la cultura
y otros no.
Nuestras historias no tienen público,
nuestras experiencias no se reflejan en lo cotidiano,
nuestras voces son un riesgo financiero muy alto.
Hace unos años me llamó mi representante
para explicarme por qué no me habían dado un papel.
Dijo: "Les encantas,
y están dispuestos a que el reparto sea diverso,
pero no se puede financiar la película hasta que tengan a los actores blancos".
Me transmitió el mensaje con el corazón roto
y con un tono que venía a decir: "Sé lo mal que está esto".
Sin embargo, como otros cientos de veces,
sentí las lágrimas rodar por mis mejillas.
La angustia por el rechazo se alzó dentro de mí
y oí la voz de la vergüenza regañándome:
"Eres una mujer adulta, no llores por un trabajo".
Durante años sufrí este proceso de aceptar los fracasos como propios
y luego sentir una profunda vergüenza por no poder superar los obstáculos.
Pero esta vez, oí una nueva voz.
Una voz que decía: "Estoy harta.
Ya basta".
Una voz que comprendía
que mis lágrimas y mi dolor no eran por perder un trabajo.
Era por lo que en realidad decían de mí.
Lo que habían dicho de mí toda la vida
ejecutivos y productores,
directores, escritores, agentes, representantes,
profesores y familiares.
Que yo era alguien con menos valor.
Pensé que la crema de protección solar y las planchas alisadoras
supondrían un cambio en este rígido sistema de valores.
Pero entonces me di cuenta,
de que nunca había pedido al sistema que cambiase.
Le pedía que me dejara entrar, y eso no es lo mismo.
No podía cambiar lo que el sistema creía sobre mí,
mientras yo creía lo que el sistema creía sobre mí.
Y lo hice.
Yo, como todos los de mi alrededor,
creía que no era posible que existiese en mi sueño tal y como era.
Por eso intenté hacerme invisible.
Lo que esto me reveló es que es posible
ser la persona que de verdad desea ver un cambio
mientras se es una persona cuyas acciones mantienen las cosas como son.
Y eso me ha llevado a creer que el cambio no vendrá
identificando los buenos y los malos.
Esa perspectiva nos salva a todos.
Porque la mayoría no somos ni lo uno ni lo otro.
El cambio vendrá
cuando todos tengamos el coraje
de cuestionarnos nuestros propios valores y creencias fundamentales.
Y ver que nuestras acciones conducen a nuestras mejores intenciones.
Soy solo una de los millones de personas
a quienes se les han dicho que para cumplir sus sueños,
para contribuir al mundo con sus talentos,
deben resistir a lo que son realmente.
Sé que estoy lista para dejar de resistir
y empezar a existir como mi yo pleno y auténtico.
Si pudiera volver atrás y decirle algo
a esa niña de nueve años que bailaba en el salón, soñando,
le diría:
mi identidad no es mi obstáculo.
Mi identidad es mi superpoder.
Porque lo cierto es que
soy lo que el mundo es.
Uds. son lo que el mundo es.
Colectivamente, todos somos lo que el mundo es en realidad.
Y para que nuestros sistemas reflejen esto,
ellos no tienen que crear una nueva realidad.
Solo tienen que dejar de resistirse a aquella en la que ya viven.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)